[Musique]
d
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'europe à l'issue d'un conseil
européen extraordinaire il portait
d'ailleurs beaucoup sur des questions
internationales
les relations entre l'union européenne
et d'autres puissances en particulier la
turquie
il a aussi été question de relance
économique en pleine pandémie de
coronavirus voilà pourquoi nous avons
choisi d'inviter aujourd'hui en duplex
de bruxelles à nous rejoindre le
commissaire en charge de l'économie et
des finances l'italien paolo john filoni
merci d'être avec nous bonjour bonjour
alors chez vous en italie vous êtes
souvent présenté comme l'homme
tranquille dans la famille des
sociaux-démocrates votre capacité à
rassembler à créer des compromis a fait
de vous le candidat idéal pour succéder
à matteo renzi à la tête du gouvernement
en 2016 après sa défaite à son
référendum
ensuite en 2018 votre parti et je suis
aux élections du gp compter du mouvement
5 étoiles prend la tête du gouvernement
de coalition avec votre parti et il
propose donc votre nom à la commission
au poste très très sensible de
l'économie et des finances vous voilà
chargé d'examiner les budgets des états
membres alors l'union européenne à
monsieur le commissaire a étonné un peu
le monde en se mettant d'accord pour une
fois sur un grand plan de relance à 550
milliards d'euros mais sa mise en oeuvre
semble patiner en est en train de
travailler jeu
je dois dire que la présidence allemande
qui est maintenant la présidence de la
de l'union européenne pour ces six mois
et est en train de travailler très
fortement pour respecter le temps et on
travaille avec le parlement je suis
confiant ce naturellement c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'avait jamais fait d'avoir
une dette commune pour des des objectifs
de toute l'union européenne
et alors ça va pas être une quelque
chose normale
c'est une chose extraordinaire mais je
suis confiant que on pourrait à
approuver ses plans de relance à
l'échéance qui est avril de l'année
prochaine
alors il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'étapes à
franchir et un moment le conseil
européen doit donner son accord la
hongrie et la pologne menacent d'opposer
le veto au plan si versement est
conditionné au respect de l'état de
droit alors que l'allemagne fait en ce
moment une proposition qui est jugé
d'ailleurs assez molle pour lier le
versement des subventions de bruxelles à
la seule bonne gestion bon peut-être
faut rappeler que la décision finale
sous sur ses 750 milliards a été prise
après 4-5 jours de négociation infini
alors les différences ne sont pas du
tout qu'on se l'est mais à la fin le but
est si important que je que je pense que
la proposition allemande par exemple sur
le rôle et à l'état de droit est une
proposition qui pourrait être renforcé à
l'avis de la commission
mais quand même c'est une proposition
qui a gagnant gagne et la majorité entre
les pays membres et qui je pense rendra
possible de avancé d'ailleurs l'état de
droit n'est pas un optionnel dans
l'union européenne
c'est le deuxième article de notre été
c'est une des composantes essentielles
de cet édifice
alors justement un blocage pourrait
venir du parlement européen il reproche
à ce plan de relance d'avoir été
concédées par les plus frugaux des
européens au détriment d'un budget à
plus long terme de l'union européenne
ils demandent en particulier une
rallonge pour ce budget donc pluri
annuelle de 100 milliards d'euros 10% du
total
il faut faire cet effort supplémentaire
pour la période 2021 2027 selon le bon
le parlement demande toujours
et justement à mon avis de renforcer le
badge est européen
parce que ce badge est multi annuelles
comme vous le savez est un badge est
très limité cette année on doit dire que
ce bilan est extrêmement plus importante
à cause d'eux les 750 milliards qu'on a
décidé pour le fonds de relance mais je
comprends très bien le fait que le
parlement demande de renforcer certains
programmes particulièrement les
programmes culturels les problèmes des
dettes d'émergence les programmes
sociaux et je pense que comme toujours
ce sera une négociation et on trouvera
quelques compromis qui naturellement ne
va pas changer les chiffres général de
cet accord qui a été trouvé après cinq
jours de négociations
l'union européenne va recourir à
l'emprunt mais aussi elle se cherche de
nouvelles ressources propres
c'est-à-dire de nouveaux impôts pour le
moment il n'y a pas mal de flou sur ses
diverses taxation avant tout s'en va
implanter des centaines de milliards sur
les marchés
en fait on commence à le faire déjà
dansé semaine sur le mécanisme qu'on
appelle jour qui est le mécanisme pour
aider le chômage partiel et
les choses de de ce genre qu'on a dans
les différents pays et c'est une
première pour la commission européenne
la commission européenne va devenir dans
les prochains trois ou quatre années un
des premier emprunteur sur les marchés
financiers on va là repayer entre 2002
26 et 2056 alors ce n'est pas demain
mais si on veut que cette extraordinaire
opérations de faire une détente commun
soit une opération de saxe et il ne peut
pas faire la dette
et puis l'art est payé en demandant aux
à chaque état membre
une contribution pour repayer
il faut leur est payé avec les
ressources propres de la commission
comme vous le disait on est en train de
travailler là la taxe sur les plastiques
sera déjà là et a été déjà décidé mais
on est en train de travailler sur de
nouveaux pistes de travail qui est un
mécanisme qui va protéger à nos
frontières
le risque que le fait qu'on est à
l'avant-garde sur la transition
climatique
et quant à l'objectif de 2 émissions
notre halle à 2050 qui conte à hausser
nos objectifs de réduction d'émissions
pour 2030
toute cette ambition européenne peut pas
se traduire dans l'affaiblissement de
notre industrie et c'est pour ça que on
aura un mécanisme en nos frontières pour
éviter que des produits qui ont un taux
d'émission de carbone très haut viennent
nous faire une concurrence qui ne sera
pas absolument accepter
alors bien sûr chaque pays est en train
du coup de peaufiner son plan de relance
et vous êtes chargé d'ailleurs de les
contrôler comme vous continuez
d'ailleurs à contrôler les budgets
nationaux et pourtant l'orthodoxie
budgétaire a été mise entre parenthèses
les règles du pacte de stabilité sont
suspendus indéfiniment sûrement serait
le restaurant suspendu pour tout le
l'année prochaine le 2021 c'était
important pour les pays qui sont en
train de faire leur budget dans ces
semaines de savoir d'avoir cette
information on aura cette suspension qui
continuera sûrement l'année prochaine
puis on discutera j'imagine le printemps
de l'année prochaine
le le moment dans lequel et la
gradualité nécessaires pour retourner à
de règles communes
parce que la france parle de l'abandon
de la règle des 3% veut passer à autre
chose en revanche l'allemagne elle veut
qu'on revienne à la rigueur
quel est votre avis quelle est votre
position on peut parvenir à ce qu'ils
étaient on peut pas en général revenir à
ce qui était aussi dans notre modèle
d'économie faut changer beaucoup de
choses on sait que on retournera pas au
niveau de croissance qu'on avait à la
fin de 2019 avant de début 2022
ah c'est ce qu'on est en train de devoir
maintenant pour l'avenir et on aura
cette année en moyenne des pays de la
zone euro une dette de son 204% c'est la
moyenne et ça vous dit que naturellement
il faudra établir une méthode très
graduelle et différencié entre pays pour
rejoindre nos règles communes
on peut pas changer les traités
européens
mais on peut pas ignorer la réalité de
notre économie
paolo gentiloni votre pays s'en tire
plutôt bien pour cette seconde vague
mais en attendant les vingt-sept
continue à définir des critères
sanitaires des règles de déplacement au
niveau national en l'absence de
coordination
c'est catastrophique pour le transport
aérien pour le business
en général la commission est incapable
d'imposer un semblant de
moniz à sion bon je dois rejeter cette
accusation
parce que écouter la commission n'a
malheureusement pas de pouvoirs en
matière de santé il y à une demande et
je me réjouis du fait qu'il tient à
cette demande dans tous les pays peut
avoir un rôle majeur de la commission
ait une coordination par exemple c'est
absolument ridicule que chacun pays
décident les zones rouges les zones
oranges les zones vertes et si on voyage
on se trouve avec des critères
complètement différent moi j'espère que
cette demande d'avoir un rôle majeur de
coordination de la commission européenne
sera transformée dans un vrai pouvoir de
coordination que pour l'instant la
commission
malheureusement n'a pas en ce qui
concerne mon pays
vous savez l'italie a eu un choc
terrible en étant le premier entre le
pays européens être sûr dans cette crise
et ce qui est très important et aussi un
peu surprenant je dois dire et le fait
qu' on est habitué à avoir une idée qui
est dans notre histoire d'ailleurs de la
méfiance des italiens envers leurs étals
les autorités la discipline mais on a vu
une situation complètement différente
dans cette crise on a eu un un niveau de
confiance dans le disions public et
sanitaires et de respect et de
discipline pour nous vraiment très
important en bois eau naturellement
maintenir le contrôle parce que on n'est
pas absolument dehors de cette crise en
italie comme en allemagne comme en
france comme en espagne
la turquie et ses ingérences en
méditerranée était à l'ordre du jour de
ce conseil européen extraordinaire
c'était même une priorité et finalement
la turquie pour le moment et bien elle
échappe aux sanctions européennes
elle en est juste menacée il faut dire
que le président ayrton avait eu la
bonne idée de rétablir le dialogue
quelques jours auparavant avec la grèce
les européens tendent la main ils
veulent même relancer l'union douanière
si la turquie cesse ces forages illégaux
dont les hot chip
alors c'est plutôt la carotte à la
carotte que propose bruxelles plutôt que
le bateau est ce que ça peut marcher
avec ar doan toujours imprévisible et
assez autocratique
mais je pense que le conseil européen a
premièrement vous lui donnez une chance
à le dialogue qui il commence et c'est
pas c'est pas encore eu un dialogue
structuré mais c'est quand même le fait
que ankara et à thème se parlent et qui
est absolument nécessaire et important
nous savons que le rôle de la turquie
s'est beaucoup renforcée dans la
dernière année on a vu leur que la
turquie a pas joué en syrie en libye que
la turquie est en train de jouer au
nagorno karabakh et mais on peut pas
accepter l'idée que cette croissance
d'importance géopolitique de la turquie
se transforme dans une déposition
inacceptable dans la méditerranée
orientale et en vert des états membres
de l'union européenne
alors c'est un peu et est une stratégie
avec deux jambes d'un côté on veut pas
éviter que le dialogue entre turquie et
grèce et peuvent peut avoir une chance
il faut lui donner une chance
mais de l'autre côté c'est très clair
que
la lymphe hortense géopolitique de la
turquie ne l'autorisent pas à faire deux
choses dans la méditerranée et envers
des états membres de l'union européenne
qui ne sont pas acceptables
on gagnera on peut avec ses deux jambes
alors plus de fermeté en revanche de ce
conseil européen sur la biélorussie
sanctions contre une quarantaine de
responsables sauf le président alexandre
loukachenko qui pourtant a falsifié
l'élection présidentielle on ne t'a pas
la tête même du pays parce que quoi on a
peur de vladimir poutine n'a encore non
je ne crois pas je je crois aussi sur la
base de mon expérience comme ministre
des affaires étrangères est aussi
premier ministre je crois que on a des
règles européennes sur la politique
étrangère qui nécessitent l'unanimité
entre le pays membres et je dois dire
que de temps en temps je me demande si
ces règles sont des règles qui peuvent
survivre dans le monde si compliqué
qu'on a donc dans les années vingt du
nouveau siècle présidente a demandé à ce
que j'ai pour les affaires étrangères et
je partage totalement
je partage totalement parce que il faut
toujours chercher l'unanimité mais on
peut pas être paralysé sur des choix si
important paolo gentiloni donc inquiets
sur l'avenir de l'europe
un merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
merci à tous de votre fidélité ici
l'europe ça continue sur france 24 et
public sénat avec ma consoeur de la
chaîne parlementaire je vous retrouve à
bruxelles pour un débat sur le pacte
migratoires entre polonais et italo
français le débat s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la seconde partie d'ici
l'europe pour notre grand débat depuis
le parlement européen la question
migratoire et l'asile donner aux
réfugiés empoisonne l'ambiance entre les
depuis le pic historique de 2015 la
commission européenne a décidé de s'y
atteler en proposant son pacte
migratoires
le 23 septembre dernier objectif affiché
un plus de solidarité entre les états
membres
ce qui à l'est ne voulait pas accueillir
les demandeurs d'asile se voit offrir la
possibilité de prendre en charge les
reconduites à la frontière mais là
encore ils traînent des pieds sur le
principe
alors les ong de défense des migrants
dénoncent vivement ce pacte de la honte
est critique
une europe à la carte avec une approche
essentiellement sécuritaire pour en
débattre aujourd'hui nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir deux anciens
ministres des affaires européennes est
venue en particulier de pologne donc un
pays fameux du groupe devise grade et
bien qui doit qui souhaitent davantage
stopper l'immigration nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir via tchèque
jarrousse bones qui ont jour vous avez
eurodéputés de proches du parti au
pouvoir ultra conservateur droit et
justice
donc ici au parlement européen
conservateurs et réformistes est venu
d'italie un pays à un premier en ligne
du flux migratoire sandro gozi
eurodéputés français du groupe centriste
heureux new proche des manuels macron
j'en profite d'ailleurs pour présenter
votre dernier livre la cible sandro gozi
vous parler de votre parcours de
l'italie jusqu'à la france vous avez
publié sur la question migratoire est
sûre ce nouveaux patins une tribune où
vous appelez à une europe où l'humain
passe avant la politique est ce que ce
pacte migratoire est une bonne réponse
c'est un début de réponse sur un
principe fondamental qui était la
présidente van der laan a aussi à
réaffirmer au parlement européen sauvé
vie en mer n'est pas une option et qu'un
dans la mer il ya des gens qui risquent
la vie on sait donc pas à qui doit
sauver que deux qui doit faire quoi on
les sauve et on assume la responsabilité
ensemble c'est ça c'est un début
d'humanité quelle europe avait oublié et
qu'il doit doit reprendre la main et
eragny était devenu le cimetière de
l'égoïsme des européens en 2014 2015
c'était une honte l'italie à l'époque à
sauver un peu la dignité européenne
je crois que ça c'est un aspect sur
lequel il faut absolument travailler du
pack migratoire alors vu de pologne est
ce que ce pacte règles l'essentiel des
problèmes qui se posent depuis à 2015 en
effet et des différents migratoires
comme il l'espérait le faire en tout cas
c'est un nouveau pacte qui en fait et
les vieux en déguisé c'est à dire les
prévoit qu'il aura une relocation
obligatoire des quotas des migrants
parmi les pays dont ceux qui étaient
déjà un échec et c'est qui a été refusé
et s'est déguisé par la voix de dire
soit vous répéterez ou des portiers le
migrant où vous les acceptez à la maison
étant donné les chiffres d'aujourd'hui
donc 29 5% le le ratio des succès des
retours
ça signifie que les quotas obligatoires
ça serrait 60 consent de déco temps
anciens donc ça change pas grand chose
si on voudrait avoir une vraie politique
européenne et l'otan ont dit quand même
que ça change grand chose en fait donc
ça change pas on vous permet de ne pas
accueillir les demandeurs d'asile ou les
réfugiés en échange sur le terme
juridique les migrants le pacte concerne
ce qui ont été refusées les droits
d'asile
donc ce sont les migrants pour faire la
politique dont vous voulez par exemple
dont renaissance ou la majorité en fait
au parlement
on pourrait les faire mais pour ça il
faut changer les traités exactement il
faut changer les traits l'article 79
points 5
qui dit que immigration et la compétence
exclusive des états membres donc la loi
proposée
c'est une violation pour contourner les
traités et c'est contre le dit vous êtes
d'accord en fin de droits
l'aviation de l'état de droit parce
qu'ils quitteraient l' or voix demande
qu'on respecte le droit l'état de droit
ça c'est une blague et news à entendre
quelqu'un du pis de la lettre vraiment
la vie que vous inquiétez vous
préoccuper de l'état doit c'est une
nouvelle pour moi vu la situation de
l'état droit en pologne mais c'est un
pas en avant considérable que
j'entendais votre voix aujourd'hui
l'autre aspect je vous invite à bien
d'autres la cour européenne de justice a
déclaré en avril dernier que vous étiez
vous-même en violation de l'état de
droit
sur la question des réfugiés justement
vous n'aviez pas pris 1 alors que vous
étiez engagé à le faire mais les traités
dit une autre chose et c'est pas un bon
mot c'est une obligation juridiquement
contraignant pour tous les pays
européens c'est que on applique la
solidarité dans l'asile et de
l'immigration
c'est une solidarité donc qui n'est pas
seulement quelque chose d fraternelle
mais des juridiquement contraignant
quand je dis solidarité que les
gouvernements polonais comme celui
hongrois notamment ont toujours refusé
et c'est trop facile vous savez d'être
solidaires quand on reçoit des fonds
européens et milliards d'euros de fonds
européens qu'on vous en pologne vous
faites et après oublier la solidarité
quand vous devez fait faire votre parti
sur la gestion au moins de demandeurs
d'asile au moins de demandeurs d'asile
parce qu'elle l'a aussi ce qui est prévu
par les traités ces incompétences
européenne
vous l'avez toujours refusé moi je
trouve cette attitude honteuse mais on
en parle et on en discute et j'espère
qu'on pourra dépasser cette attitude
arriver à un compromis acceptable pour
tout le monde
premièrement si vous permettez on peut
pas utiliser les mots solidarité vous en
france explique vous avez inventé
liberté égalité fraternité nous en
pologne on a inventé
si vous pouvez en termes politiques
solidarité solidarité et les catégories
quart d'heure mais eux c'est en
autonomie l'un n'exclut l'autre
solidarité c'est seulement volontaire
qui vient de la volonté pure à libre ne
peut pas être renforcé en force et
obligatoire cette fois c'est le nom ses
relances action la transaction les
fronts oui ou non que donc on pourrait
on pourrait me rendre volontaire aussi
avec la politique de cohésion économique
et sociale quoi dé cohésion territoriale
vous donc on pourrait dire des monstres
on avait grandement en 2021 j'ai pas
envie de la majorité la compensation de
l'esprit par rapport à là où l'ouverture
vous étiez au cabinet prodi s'est arrêté
le le marché interdire l inspection de
sa région et la compensation de
l'ouverture des marchés pour cette
raison le pays comme norvège paix aux
autres pour pouvoir entrer et profiter
du marché n'est donc lyon ça rien à voir
avec solidarité sas et en actions ça
c'est ça c'est une façon de voir les
choses qui va très bien dans les stands
et varsovie et vous en pologne
vous avez toujours refusé d'aider à
résoudre les problèmes de l'asile et des
migrations dont vous avez violé les
principes de sécurité et ins et ses
vassaux leader alors bien sûr le pire le
pays responsable de la demande pourrait
être celui où un migrant a des liens
familiaux où il a travaillé ou étudier
ou alors le pays lui ayant délivré un
visa
un état soumis à une pression migratoire
pourra demander un l'activation d'un
mécanisme de solidarité obligatoire est
ce que pour vous notamment en italie ça
va être un soulagement immédiat
oui c'était par les dépassements des
deux
donc on avait promis auquel je croyais
pas parce que vous voyez même à la
lumière de cette débat qu'on a
aujourd'hui légitime mais qui par des
positions très éloignées
je doute qu'on pourra dépasser dublin je
les regrette c'est à dire renvoyé au
pays d'origine tout ça veut dire que du
moment où seule critique que j'ai fait à
la commission européenne
dans cette lancée quand est-ce qu'ils
ont parlé des dépassements et du blanc
c'est bien de faire de la communication
mais il faut éviter d'élever des ad dos
et les attentes ce n'est pas un
dépassement et du blanc mais on essaie
de rendre double en plus intelligent
parce qu'elle règle qui met tout la
charge sur les pays des frontières
maritimes alors qu'ils sont la honte on
qu'effrontées européenne pour protéger
pour régler pour gérer la libre
circulation à l'intérieur de l'union
européenne et règles stupides qui doit
être dépassé donc essayons de rendre
dublin plus intelligents et les les
propositions que vous avez dit
réunification familiale
disons mécanisme plus souple et plus
rapide d'évaluation des demandes et des
redistributions vont sans doute dans le
bon sens mais il faut qu'il soit
beaucoup plus simple et beaucoup plus
rapide par rapport à la proposition de
la commission selon alors quand on parle
de solidarité cet été le camp de
réfugiés de moria sur l'île grecque de
lesbos le plus grand d'europe à
entièrement brûlé une catastrophe que
mentionne d'ailleurs à la présidente de
la commission européenne pour justifier
l'urgence de sa réforme son pacte
migratoires on les coûts tout de suite
et les noirs recrachés web
la question n est pas de ce joueur sur
l'iso un nombre d'oies séance de
solidaires et contribuer à aider haïti
mais comment ils doivent le faire maria
a été un rappel brutal
oui mais de vous trouver des solutions
durables en matière de migration en tous
nous mobiliser
qu'est-ce qu'on fait face à moriat
justement quand on parlait de cette
solidarité du côté polonais vous avez
regardé les images comme le reste de
l'europe
et vous n'avez pas été touché et ému et
vous dites il est temps qu'on les
accueille nous aussi la pologne était le
premier où parmi les premiers pays qui
ont envoyé des maisons spéciaux
mobile en grand chiffre à 1 moria pour
abriter ce qui n'ont pas ou qu'ils ont
perdu la main et qui reste là bas c'est
ça que vous dites non plus pour qui
s'abritent pour qu ils s'abritent parce
qu'il faut il faut ce que nous ayons de
l'aider dès le début les gens comme
c'est un problème grec quoi c'est un
problème grec et vous voulez bien les
délais n'ont soudain c'est un problème
que doit être résultats renvoi de ces
gens et nos pour l'admission à
l'intérieur de frontières de l'union
européenne c'est qu'il ya d'ailleurs dit
dans le schéma d'alternât sionneau
encore la solidarité elle est
obligatoire parce qu'on a tous signé
pour le pollen comprise des traités
d'asile internationaux l'immigration
zéro parce que vous ne voulez pas qu'on
gère que l'europe chez à l'immigration
voulait qu'on stoppe l'immigration ligne
admettons poèmes pour un moment que je
suis pour votre vision de l'immigration
de la politique d'immigration au niveau
européen on peut le faire seulement en
changeant les traiter ça se sent ah oui
partie seulement pas arctique en soit
les centres monteront de la non non non
sinon la brasseuse et aujourd'hui vous
démontrez aussi et vous refusez on peut
on peut on peut avoir comme une 19e
avoir un c'est la compétence exclusive
des pays membres sur la joue les seconds
détourner les gars on peut et on doit
développer des politiques communes parce
qu'il ya chaque viennent quand même et
c'est trop facile et je consigne
vermeille est composé des maisons
mobiles pour des réfugiés qui fuient les
djihadistes de la syrie parce qu'il ya
le droit international et la pologne
fait partie dé l'onu et la pologne est
lié à au droit international humanitaire
vaut à vernir obligations de la
convention d une belle
des arguments c'est moins cher et
émotionnel non non c'est pas un
perfectionnement c'est du droit
international c'est la combustion de
genève s'il ya des gens qui fuient les
guerres et les persécutions et la rive
dans l'union européenne
tous les pays européens devraient les
aider merci monsieur chine envoie les
maisons et les six mois les maisons
allant de 12 à lampedusa ne sont des
migrants vous répond ce sont des
migrants depuis de savoir si c'est un
micro on doit évaluer sa demande c'est
pas marqué sur l'elysée la convention de
genève vous trompez de sa réserve tissu
de ce pacte et monsieur jacques douadi
vise en effet à clarifier pacte
migratoires et de l'asile donc les deux
ailes et 2 tenant des juniors quoi vous
né comte ne voulait pas compté les
migrants venant de l'est
c'est pas une question d comptait au
départ comptait 5 et serait cas il ya
une crise on doit être solidaire et
celle points mais il y à une guerre ans
en ukraine
il y à un état de guerre en biélorussie
nous rêvons de migrants on délaisse vous
et vous dites ça compte pas seulement
dessus de 50 personnes à sa digue et ça
compte mais oui il a raison nous avons
refusé de voter les textes vous dites
qu'elle sait qu'il faudra reconnaissez
qui s'est passé ça me gratte war c est
sûr c'est qu'ils se passent en turquie
pour vous n'existez pas comme nous
aveugle comme ça l'est encore de
l'amazonie d'accord pour moi d'en goûter
pour que si si si l'union européenne
comptait également les ukrainiens et
qu'elles étaient relogées par vous dans
les camps et c'est que cette solidarité
soit global et que vous preniez entre
les changements de traité apic 72
voulait que dut d'ukrainiens et vous
voulez choisir vos migrants nous voulons
que ça respecte le traité article 69 ans
on a compris monsieur monsieur va
prendre l'avancé une des propositions
dans mes dessins de sony se sont mis
nation et me disent ils car si son
bonheur et peut-être musulmans ne
s'amusait pas là
ces deux à six mois bon oui bah moi
c'est pas bon c'est pas moi c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est l'engager racisme
oui c'est pas ses états membres
oui vous êtes bilingue douleur qu'ont
argument fait pas j'ai pas entendu ça
j'ai dit sur son banquet donc ce moment
que vous faites les discours oui de
lucre un essai et s'ils ont un problème
avec l'afrique si on a un problème
vraiment in orion et ses enfants ont un
problème avec l'amérique latine qu'est
ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on sait vous
n'aurez répondez vous mais si vous
comptez seulement le mien la migration -
du 10 mai rendez vous et moi c'est que
moi j'ai raison tant qu'européen donc
pour moi vos problèmes d'eau et vous
raisonnez comme dans le btp des supports
malte italie et france sur moi vos
problèmes sont mes problèmes pour vous
les problèmes vous réalisez que mes
problèmes et l'espagne vous rendez vous
mais vous avez toujours bloqués des
solutions communes et votre attitude
aujourd'hui démontre que vous êtes prêt
encore à bloquer une solution commune
avec les pas tenir at war vous dites les
packs migratoire était légale on doit
modifier les traités cette info vous
messieurs dérive ou pas vous cacher
derrière ça ça à creuser encore l'écart
et vous dit non ça ne sera jamais un
combat maintenant on c'est un vieux
problème c'est dépit des puis quand on a
déjà soulevé ce problème il y a trois
ans au conseil des chefs d'état et
gouvernement vos pays est là le groupe
visio gratte pologne hongrie république
tchèque mon psy est posée c'est ça vous
pensez à ces pactes oui oui parce qu'ils
violent le traité
donc la commission européenne a fait une
proposition en violation et traitait ce
oui c'est pas la première fois très bien
joué très bien et elle doit d'abord elle
même d'une donner l'exemple de respecte
de droit de l état de droit
j'ai pensé à mes choses car j'ai été
quand je fait recours à la cour de
justice contre la pologne vous avez été
condamné j'ai pensé la même chose et la
pologne
la différence entre vous et moi et moi
j'ai un jugement de la cour de justice
de mon côté vous n'avez rien de votre
côté dans votre affirmation
merci fait sur les 300 vols unis on voit
bien que vous êtes deux plaques
tectoniques qui dérivait effectivement
et que ce pacte migratoire
malheureusement ne vous a pas rapprochés
c'est très
évidemment visible sur ce plateau merci
d'avoir très bien illustré ce débat
clivant vous restez sur nos antennes à
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]